[Music]
interesting developments over the past
24 hours as it relates to something that
Chris Sims casually mentioned during an
episode of PFT ot last week when we were
discussing players that are untouchable
from a trade standpoint that all came up
because the Bengals insist there was no
way no how they were giving up the
number one overall pick they wanted Joe
borough which is ludicrous because he's
not yet untouchable
we agreed that Pat mahomes is Lamar
Jackson is Aaron Donald likely is Aaron
Rodgers because of his contract this
year is we talked about Russell Wilson
and Chris Sims mentioned that proud of
the 2018 draft there was a conversation
between the Seahawks and the Browns
about a possible trade of Wilson to
Cleveland for the number one overall
pick in the draft and I didn't think
anything of it at the time but as the
past seven days unfolded reporters were
hearing what he had to say people were
picking it up and more importantly and
here's how it hit my radar screen
yesterday big cap people who are in the
know as to what did or didn't happen
were starting to be contacted by
reporters who were chasing the story so
I started to hear from these people
saying what the hell did you guys say so
it's like I've I don't know I found the
clip I passed it around and we then you
know and this is something that fell
into our lap I want people to understand
we're not out there trying to shake the
trees for some sort of a hot take that
we can use to fuel a slow news cycle and
maybe we should have but this is
something that just fell out of the sky
and I'm not going to ignore it when it
falls out of the sky and big-cat the
information I got yesterday tells me
there was a conversation there was a
conceptual discussion between the
Seahawks and the Browns regarding a
Russell Wilson trade and it comes down
to this the debate and we've talked
about this before the debate that a team
will necessarily have when it comes to
pay a huge amount of money to a
quarterback at what point do you say
I'd rather have young cheap players even
if it's the first overall pick in the
draft it's gonna cost me a hell of a lot
less the four-year contract is gonna
cost me less than one year average with
the deal that this player wants that's
why a team would consider it and when
you look at the Seahawks greatest
success of the last decade when did it
happen
more muscle Wilson was working under his
rookie contract I
can I say Mike that I actually if I were
Russell Wilson I would be happy that
this actually happened and that's simply
because that means that the organization
I play for is always thinking in a smart
way and that I I think they made the
right decision because Russell Wilson is
a top five top three quarterback in the
NFL and it's hard to find a guy like
that they don't grow on trees but if you
are a fan of the Seahawks and you see
this news you should be happy not mad
because at the end of the day if when
when you're rooting for your team you
want your front office you want your
organization to always try to think
ahead and how they can figure out a way
to stay competitive year in and year out
did they get close to doing this
probably not but the fact that they
picked up a phone and did their due
diligence and and looked around and just
weighed all their options is exactly
what I want them to do if I were a fan
of the Seahawks and if you're Russell
Wilson it's exactly what I want the tone
to be in the organization that they will
always look to everywhere to every
single place to every single Avenue when
it comes to trade free agency draft
whatever it may be to make the team
better so this is a tricky situation
where people could probably take it the
wrong way
but I see this is nothing more than the
Seahawks doing a great job of at least
seeing because what happens Mike what
happens if you call up and someone
offers you I didn't even know what the
max is but they offer you three four
picks first-round picks for Russell
Wilson I'm not again I'm not saying that
you should do it because Russell Wilson
is that good and you probably should
keep him on your team but it's worth
exploring that option and it's worth at
least hearing someone say yeah I agree
with you completely and it is smart to
always be thinking about what you can do
with the current assets you have and how
you can maximize those assets in the
future and when you have that much money
devoted to one player it's at least
worth considering what else you could do
especially when at the time the Seahawks
knew they were a year away from giving
Russell Wilson what still is the richest
contract in league history and before he
signed that contract and he imposed a
deadline on them and usually these
artificial deadlines don't work Russell
set the deadline and the team complied
with it which the team probably
at some level because these teams like
to be the ones who dictate to the
players not the other way around
Wilson was on Jimmy Fallon and I
remember last year Sims and I were
laughing about it when Fallon asks
Wilson about the possibility being the
highest-paid player in the NFL that
doesn't seem like something that falls
naturally into Jimmy Fallon's range of
expertise or things he would give a crap
about right and and so Wilson knew what
he was doing and the fact that there's a
no-trade clause in his contract
we should not view that as some sort of
an accidental blip Wilson and his agent
wanted to be sure that they couldn't do
this to him without him being involved
in the process and you know the idea
that he could be traded in the future
and there are people who believe it
could still happen and Seahawks fans
will say he's got a no trade clause it
can't happen it's like folks just
because he has a no trade clause doesn't
mean he can't be traded he can veto any
trade if it's a trade he likes he can
say I'll waive my no trade clause if
you're trading me to this team this team
of this team and teams that I think it
makes sense to watch the Raiders because
of John Gruden's perpetual love for
quarterbacks and also he could talk to
this one without standing on a stepstool
the Cowboys who are gonna have to pay
somebody a ton of money if I gotta pay
dak Prescott a ton of money I'd rather
pay that money to a more proven
commodity and Russell Wilson
we love you dak but it's the truth and
then maybe the Saints Post Drew Brees
the problem though is the Saints are
gonna have to move on next year most
likely without Brees you can't trade
Russell Wilson in 2021 the cap hit would
be too big for the Seahawks this is
something that would happen if at all in
2022 or 2023 as he gets closer to that
next big contract and the reason that
Wilson is able to drive such a hard
bargain you know he does short term
deals four-year extensions his agent
Mark Rodgers is not a football agent so
he doesn't have all these tentacles and
relationships he needs to worry about
where if you push too hard with this
client they're gonna get you with that
client and you have to be sensitive to
having that right tone having that right
atmosphere with all the people you
negotiate with from Rogers perspective I
got one guy on ago she ate on behalf of
and I'm gonna get in the best possible
deal and if you don't like it tough crap
and that's one of the reasons I think
why the Seahawks would at least
entertain the possibility of getting a
quarterback who's represented by someone
that they can maybe exert a little more
leverage over because that guy
represents five other players on their
team all right well that was a no
sarcasm great wrinkle from you Mike
Florio I actually really enjoy when you
dropped those knowledge bombs because I
didn't realize that dynamic was at play
the other reason that Russell Wilson can
can dictate the terms is he's really
really really really really good at
football and get in and like I said at
the start those guys don't grow on trees
and every single franchise in the NFL is
constantly looking for their Russell
Wilson and if you actually did a list of
all the quarterbacks you know which I'm
sure we will do in a couple weeks
because there's still no sports we would
we would probably put Russell Wilson in
that two three four slot and you would
say to yourself how many teams would
trade that you know mortgage the future
for a guy like Russell Wilson today and
guess what the list is I don't know 25
deep whatever it may be there are a lot
of teams that would be lining at the
door for a guy like Russell Wilson to be
their quarterback so he's in the
ultimate you know position of power
because not only does they have the
agent dynamic you've just talked about
the short-term deals but guess what all
of his play and all of his talent backs
up all of it oh yeah absolutely right
and you know here's the thing he's going
to be able to try to push the bar even
higher than it already is he's gonna
have a chance to push it past Pat
mahomes and if anyone does trade for him
at some point they're gonna have to
balance what they give the Seahawks for
Russell Wilson Plus what they're willing
to pay him because they're most likely
going to give him a new contract on the
way through the door but but back to the
original point this is a very real
dynamic where teams engage in that
cost-benefit analysis of clinging to a
quarterback who is taking up a huge
chunk of the salary cap versus rolling
the dice on a young guy who they can
have for four years maybe five with a
fifth year option at an affordable rate
and when you look at how much
college quarterbacks are coming into the
NFL than they used to be it's just a
matter of time before somebody does it
before somebody says we're just not
doing it it's not just gonna be the
Bears in mitts true Biscay when it's
obvious they shouldn't pick up the
fifth-year option to give him a
long-term contract it's gonna be
somebody that we look at and say hey
that guy's pretty good why are they not
keeping him and you know what big cat in
hindsight it's probably what the Rams
should have done with your guy Jared
Goff yeah you don't say that you you
went a little too far there you didn't
have to say that you really did have to
say it I know I wanted to well next
we're gonna have these guys coming up
right like these guys the Baker Mayfield
Josh Rosen obviously not but Josh Allen
Sam darn old Lamar Jackson draft is
going to be coming up in the next year
so that will be a very interesting
dynamic because you could make a case
one way or the other with probably all
those guys when it comes to picking up
their fifth year option and the best
move for any of these teams to make the
moment the third regular season ends for
these guys that they choose to keep get
them signed to a long-term contract then
in there the longer you wait the more
expensive it gets just look at what the
Cowboys are going through with that
press
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports